[music playing]
NARRATOR: As experts begin to
search for other explanations,
they turn their
attention to a series
of disturbing
discoveries that occurred
in the months following
the June 2012 attacks.
We had some dolphins that
washed up already dead.
We weren't really
sure what it was,
but we did hear
from other states
that they were having
the same issue.
NARRATOR: In fact, it turns out
that over the course of 2013,
a total of 48 dolphins are found
dead on South Carolina beaches.
Researchers concluded the
dolphins were inflicted
with the morbillivirus.
This deadly disease suppresses
the dolphin's immune system
and causes inflammation
of the brain.
The result is a bizarre
shift in behavior.
Infected dolphins
have been witnessed
swimming in strange patterns,
almost like they are drunk.
And additional
research has shown
that brain inflammation
in zebrafish
caused them to
become more agitated.
So in 2012, could the
sharks of Myrtle Beach
have been inflicted
with a disease that
changed their
behavior, making them
more likely to bite swimmers?
According to Dr. Dan
Huber, it comes down
to a shark's immune system.
DAN HUBER: For
animals, the skin is
the first line of
defense against any type
of an infection.
So the skin is part of the
immune system, essentially.
Looking at a section of
shark skin which shows what
are called dermal
denticles, which
are basically little teeth that
make up the scales of a shark.
NARRATOR: The denticles
perform a unique function
in the shark's immune system.
DAN HUBER: Dermal
denticles creates
a very uneven
shape that bacteria
have a hard time adhering to.
Because the bacteria
can't adhere to it,
they can't form colonies.
And this is something
that helps sharks
to resist bacterial infections.
NARRATOR: And there's also
another organ that helps
protect sharks from disease--
their liver.
The liver produces a chemical
compound called squalamine.
The squalamine is dispersed
inside the shark's cells.
If a virus invades the
cells, the squalamine
prevents it from multiplying
so the virus doesn't spread.
And the shark doesn't get sick.
Scientists are even testing
squalamine to fight cancer
in humans.
This remarkable
immune system means
that sharks might
be one of the most
disease-resistant
creatures on Earth.
Any suggestion that the
sharks could have become ill due
to a virus or a
bacterial infection
isn't very likely
because sharks have
very strong immune systems.